If you were trapped in a survival game
where you and 11 others could predict
when you'll die, what would you do?
When everyone can predict the future?
How do you outsmart them to win the game?
I'm here to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do, and how to beat
the diary owners in FUTURE DIARY.
This kid's life is about to change
forever.
Yuki, here is your typical
run of the mill loser.
No one in his school wants to talk to him,
and he spends his days
staring at his phone
with no social life whatsoever.
He spends a lot of time
writing in his diary on his phone
without any reason at all.
But this small habit of his is going
to destroy the entire world at home.
He closes his eyes and enters
a whole new dimension
with the king of time and space.
DEUS, his imaginary friend.
However, he's not alone. Deus.
This is helper member.
Murray is there as well, making fun of him
for always writing and his secret diary.
The man is lonely,
but Deus gives him a way to fix his life
by playing a simple game.
The next day, Yuki wakes up
and reads a news report on his phone
about a serial killer
who killed someone near his school.
The phone texts him the rest of his day
with timestamps and intricate details,
but the kid doesn't realize
that he's discovered
something that will change his life
forever.
He gets up and throws a dart,
which lands on a double bullseye.
Exactly.
As it was written on the text in school.
Later, he checks his phone again
to find out that all the answers
have been written down for him
to follow on his phone throughout the day.
He watches
as every single part of the text
that he receives begin to come true,
right down to the smallest details.
Confused.
He goes back into the other dimension
and asks us what the hell is going on?
And that's
when this imaginary space diety.
He tells him the most insane thing.
He tells them that he is a
real God and that Yuki now possesses
something called a future diary.
This device allows you to see the future,
but if the diary breaks,
if the phone breaks, the owner dies. Wow.
That is a lot to take in
for a high school student.
If it were me, though,
I would be thinking about all
the possible opportunities presented to us
now that we can predict the future
We've just discovered a device that can
solve all of our problems, fix world
peace, and change my life forever now.
The first thing I would do
would be to get an extremely durable
phone cover, because you never know
when you might drop your phone
and instantly die, and that would suck.
However, with great power comes great
responsibility and blah blah blah.
as that saying goes.
We have a literal God giving us
this device to predict the future.
But I have a strong feeling that it's
not going to be worth the hassle.
I would kindly ask a US to pick somebody
else to bless with this magical ability
while Yuki's live here might seem pretty
damn bad, he's got no friends.
He's a Shut-In.
Getting an infinitely powerful device
like this while still going through
puberty is not going to turn out well.
So if I was him, I'd avoid
my teenage angst
and ask Deus to get rid of my new powers
ASAP.
The next day. Exams are in session.
Yuki receives the answers to all of his
upcoming exams in his phone diary,
and just as he's about to pass the test
with flying colors, this pink haired girl,
Yuno, glances at him for a split second.
He doesn't realize it, but
this girl knows exactly what's going on.
When school is finished for the day,
he gets a terrifying new text
that says At 6 p.m.
on the dot
somebody will follow him home to kill him.
Shocked, the pink haired girl from before
tells him that this is his future.
He then runs out of the school
and sees on his phone
that the future is changing by the second
sprinting through the city, he runs home.
But this girl won't stop chasing him
and she opens the elevator door
to kiss him on the lips.
She mentions that she can see
the future as well, and that she knew
that Yuki wouldn't retaliate with violence
as the elevator is going up.
Yuno, points out that another
serial killer is lurking from the ground.
She mentions that he's the third
diary owner and that she scared
the killer away from killing Yuki
because her diary is focused only on Yuki.
And she can predict his future
every 10 minutes.
She then presses the button
for the rooftop and shows
that if he were to have left
on the 14th floor, he would have died.
And she reveals that he's been entered
into a death game with other people
just like him.
Yuno, mentions that the killer near them
will find their location
and says that
they'll do better out in the open
in order to escape before it's too late.
Just then,
the killer enters from the elevator doors
and walks out onto the rooftop,
only to find its empty right.
As Yuki hides nearby
waiting for the perfect time to strike.
Then all of a sudden, Yuno grabs
the killer's attention from behind,
and two Yuki hurls a dart
right into his phone,
destroying the phone
and killing the killer. Cold.
Okay. Yeah, that was some crazy shit.
And they should be patting themselves
on the back for that smart play.
But Yuki here has a lot more diary owners
to face in the coming days.
It's a lot of information
to take in diaries,
weirdly dressed, people trying to kill us
and to knowing exactly
what's going to happen in the future.
There's a lot of uncertainty going on,
which means we'll need to be thinking
two steps ahead at all times
if we want to beat this death game.
And as Deus explained, every single
contestant's diary can potentially predict
what's going to happen
90 days into the future.
Now, this weird, hyperbolic time chamber
like area that we're in is probably
going to be
the only chance we get to see our enemies
before they find us in the real world.
I'm not entirely sure
how phones would work in this situation,
but since our diary is our phone
and we do have it with us
it might be useful to take some photos of
the other contestants if Deus allows it.
Assuming the other contestants
view us as silhouettes
just like we view them,
it might be possible to do it
without anyone noticing.
From there,
we could make up a fake story
as to why we need to identify
these individuals at the police station
and go from there.
Now, the important thing
that most of these contestants
probably aren't considering is the fact
that this is a survival game.
This means that all we have to do
is survive and we win the game.
Being a teenager,
we have the upper hand in this situation
because we're
probably one of the youngest here,
which gives us a number of advantages.
It seems like, Yuno, here is willing to do
anything to win us over
and I mean anything.
And while that's definitely not
what you would want
in a normal, healthy relationship,
it is great for us right here.
All we have to do is to pretend
we're hot as hell for her.
And she will do whatever she can
to save us if possible.
I would take her someplace far away
where none of the other contestants
could possibly find us,
even with their diaries.
Once enough time has passed
and I've estimated
that the rest of the contestants are dead.
I'd kill her with my charm
and maybe a knife and win the game.
Chatting with deers,
Yuki gets angry at him
for not telling the truth
about the other contestants,
and he is transported to another room
where
the silhouettes of other diary holders
congratulate him on having the first day.
US then explains that the entries
and their diaries stretch up to 90 days
into the future and adds
that the future can change depending
on whether or not the contestant follows
what the diary has set out for that,
meaning the future truly is malleable.
Deist gives them a final piece
of information.
A contestant's future will change
when one of them wants to kill the other.
This is called a death entry.
A contestant who receives this change in
the future is given a dead end to call
and must do everything
he or she can do to avoid it.
Deus announces to everyone that the winner
will be given his throne and become a God
if they can survive.
But sends Yuki
here was the first to get a kill.
Everyone now has set their sights on him
as their first target.
That sucks.
Later, after class, Yuki approaches Yuno
to learn more about the game.
And that's when this purple haired girl
pops in and says that the serial killer
that they just killed is actually dead.
Right as she peeks at Yuki cell
phone and realizes that he's the first.
Suddenly, Yuno, rushes in and attacks
this chick before she reveals herself
as the ninth contestant
blowing up the entire school.
In an instant, they survived the bombing,
and Yuki here promises to kill the ninth
outside the purple haired girl announces
to the whole school
that bomb sensors
have been placed all around the building.
Just as Yuki reads that there's explosions
on the stairs since he has the random
diary, he is not allowed to influence
what future predictions are given to him.
Just then, he sees that class to see
is about to explode right before
Yuki comes in swinging saving his ass
in the nick of time.
Well, I think anyone could have seen
that coming a mile away NO, no normal
person dresses in a corset
while going to high school.
What are they at?
Anime Convention?
Not to mention the previous diary owner.
We just kill.
It had a pretty eccentric
fashion sense as well.
So from now on
I would think it's safe to assume
that anyone we see dressing up as weird
looking characters, we should
then get ourselves ready for some action.
Now, even though the situation looks
pretty dang bad, we're extremely lucky
to have avoided multiple explosions
that could have easily killed us.
Looking on the bright side of things,
folks, it's too against one.
And this girl, Yuno, is ready to do
damn near anything to keep us safe.
That's a valuable thing to keep in mind
when trying to survive a red hot situation
using the diary.
We know that going down
any of the stairs is going to cause
another explosion leading to our deaths.
This means that we really need
to really think
outside of the box to escape the ninth.
One option that we would have
would be to scale the wall
on the other side of the building,
which she can't see us from.
However, that's a lot
easier said than done,
and you need to have the grip strength
of a rock climber
and the balls to make it down
without falling to your death.
Now, it might sound coldblooded,
but there could be a way of getting out
that might sound simpler than expected.
The ninth
purposely announced on loudspeaker
that the bonds are activated by sensors.
This means that hundreds of students
currently stuck in
the building
are at risk of getting blown to shreds
as well if they make any wrong moves.
However, when enough time passes,
someone's going to take a chance.
And that's our key to escape.
Our random
diary is going to tell us exactly
where the bomb blasts are happening.
And luckily for us,
all we have to do is stay
put in a classroom
that's already been blown up and wait it
out, whether it takes minutes or hours.
Eventually, the teachers, students,
someone will lose their cool
and try running down the stairs.
They'll explode and they'll die.
Sucks to be that,
but it will also create a safe
pathway for us to leave the building
and deal with the ninth, either outside
or in the near future,
right before they make their way
through the building
while avoiding the explosions.
Using his diary,
however, Yuki's diary is in focused on
what happens to himself
so he can't figure out
what's going to happen in the future.
Suddenly, Yuki gets a text
that he's about to be severely wounded,
just as they survive
the chaos from within.
Walking through the hallways,
everything seems to be going fine.
But that's when Yuki sees his classmates
and runs over to greet him.
They push him down after hearing that
the ninth told them to capture Yuki,
asking them to take his cell phone
in exchange for being set free.
The students bring him downstairs
and the Ninth gets ready to kill him.
But that's when Yuno
runs out of the classroom
to save him, detonating the bombs
from within the building,
she announces that the rest of the bombs
will go off in 10 minutes,
killing everyone in the surrounding area.
But her plans are cut short
when a mysterious man interrupts
the standoff and introduces himself
as the fourth contestant and tells Yuki
that he's not the one being targeted.
But the ninth is actually
after the fourth.
This cop guy,
this guy has the investigation
diary, meaning
he can see crimes happening in the future.
He tells Yuki
that he's not interested in becoming God
and only wants to solve crimes
to help people.
However, the ninth is done,
she threatens to bomb
the entire surrounding area,
which causes the detective
to change his mind
and points his gun towards Yuki.
But suddenly Yuno jumps from the building
window and tries attacking the ninth.
The detective tells him to get his diary,
and he runs through the landmines
with Yuno help grabbing the diary
and pissing off the ninth,
she rushes towards Yuno
and throws her over,
getting ready to detonate the bombs
and take everyone out.
But she's suddenly interrupted
by the other students who throw books
and everything that they have on them
down on her to distract her.
While she looks away,
Yuno runs towards her and stabs her
right in the eye with no other option.
She creates a smoke cloud
and drives a motorcycle out of the school
before revealing that she's
the owner of the Escape Diary, meaning
she can escape any sticky situation
with ease forcing the fourth AKA,
this detective guy to invite the two
to form an alliance with him in order
to hunt down the remaining contestants.
Okay.
After this incident, we're now all well
and truly settled into the insanity
of this survival game.
Our schools just been destroyed.
A girl just literally whipped
a motorcycle out of her ass,
and there's a police officer
trying to negotiate with a teenage boy.
I think it's time we take a breather
from all of this ridiculousness.
Now, the first thing I would do
is to realize that going to school
is not a good idea.
Schools are an easy place to get tracks,
and you're going to get hundreds
of innocent people killed
if you care about that.
In fact, the entire city is probably not
a good place to be. Living in right now.
While Dallas could have picked anyone
to become a diary owner
and take his place as God,
it seems like he only picked Japanese
people while living in Sakurami City.
As rightful candidates.
If it were me,
I would get the next train out of Dodge
and leave as soon as possible.
It doesn't matter where I'm going,
it just needs to be out of the city now.
If we had some kind of money or access
to funds, it would probably be a good idea
to leave the entire country.
However, I doubt that Yuki
here has the finances to do so.
So just to be safe
I would use, Yuno, as protection and play
like a fiddle,
as in pretend to fake my love
for her as hard as possible
because she's extremely gullible.
But she's also an incredibly terrifying,
knife wielding badass.
So we kind of have to dance on the knife
edge here a little bit.
Since we'll be called occasionally
to meet up with the other diary owners.
I should be able to find out
exactly when there's no one
left and kill, Yuno, myself
in order to win the survival game.
And frankly, Yuno
would probably let me kill her anyways.
The fourth explains
that they need to identify the remaining
seven out of 12 contestants,
but that their main target is the ninth.
Later that night, they walk back home
before, Yuno, invites him to come over.
Inside, Yuki goes to take a leak and walks
through the dark hallways
to reach the bathroom.
He then notices a strange room
with duct tape all over and decides
to take a look and find something
that he'll never forget.
Dead bodies
everywhere, sprawled out around the room,
leaving the boy frozen in shock
just as Yuno shows up
out of nowhere and questions
what he's up to.
Yuki then runs away
and locks himself in his house
as Yuno's head slips
through to wish him a creepy good night.
But the horrors aren't over for him.
Oh, no, no, no.
As Yuki wonders,
just what the hell he saw
and even thinks about calling the police,
just as Yuno heads them up
and tells him to chill out
on that thought, proving to Yuki
that escaping this hellhole is impossible
and that the worst for this death
game is yet to come.
The next day forth picks up Yuki
at his house along with Creepshow, Yuno,
and he tells them
that the ninth has been captured
by a religious group
arriving at the temple.
This lady introduces herself
as the priestess
and explains that her eyesight is limited,
forcing her to have to reside indoors.
For most of her life.
And she reveals
that she's the sixth contestant, but
she tells them that she has no interest
in becoming God and isn't a threat.
She then shows them her diary, which
reveals that she's going to die tonight
holding the ninth underground.
She offers them a trade
hand over the ninth
in exchange for Yuki later on the sixth
and Yuki have a private conversation
telling him to not trust.
Yuno, however, Yuno,
his diary is detailing
everything she's saying
and suddenly the wooden cage
catches on fire
and her disciples begin
murdering each other in cold blood.
Yuno,
tells him to not save the Sixth since,
The diary says he'll die in the process,
but Yuki says that he doesn't trust her
because of the night before and runs
to the cage to save the priestess.
That's
when suddenly the sprinklers activate
and the sixth commands everyone
to stop killing each other.
She tells Yuki that someone
must be controlling her disciples.
She then tries
to check the location of the enemy
by checking her
diary and finds that someone suspicious
is staying in the lodge.
And they find a more and more suspicious
person reports around the area
before they realize
that the disciples
have been hypnotized again,
causing the diary to show inaccurate
reports they decide to walk outside.
As Yuno, here
gets jealous with green envy of Yuki
and the priestesses new friendship.
However, they don't have time to argue
because their diary suddenly changes
showing Yuki has a dead end flag.
Horrified.
They have no idea
where the threat is coming from,
but that's when, Yuno, slashes
the head of a dead corpse.
Suddenly the corpses rise
from the dead and begin attacking them.
Just then, Yuno, gives Yuki the option
of staying with her and the living
or trusting the sixth and dying she's
the only one targeted by the disciples.
So all they have to do is leave,
and they'll be free of any danger,
Yuno, pulls them away to get out.
But Yuki brings the priestess along.
Meanwhile, fourth
year calls Yuki to inform him
that he'll continue investigating
the whereabouts of the ninth,
and he's just called back up to help them
get out of the temple.
They run as fast as possible,
but the girls get into a disagreement
which stops their progress.
The detective then calls up Yuki again
and tells them to watch out
as the 12th is headed his way.
He then informs him that the contestant is
blind but has amazing hearing skills.
Just then they suddenly spot
a group of 12 on a nearby roof.
One of them is the real 12th,
but they don't know who
the group of 12 jumps down.
It gets ready to attack,
but they stop to mention
that their only target is the priestess.
The six is tracking them,
and she's more of a cult leader
than she is a priestess, and tells them
that out of the five twelves,
one of them has swallowed a time bomb
which will soon detonate.
Yuki then reveals that a dead end
flag has been set for him,
but he's willing to do whatever it takes
to kill the priestess.
Okay,
Yuki here just missed a very big chance
to take out two contestants in one go.
This is.
This is going to put him
in a world of trouble real soon.
Okay.
Now, while you might seem like a crazy
b...,
You know the word at the moment,
it seems like she definitely
has our best interests in mind.
This doesn't seem like that
complex of an issue, folks.
There are no friends in this game,
so unless you're crazy, like, Yuno,
then no contestants should be
making alliances with each other.
Neither the 12th or the sixth
are on our side,
and the sixth is nearly blind,
which means there's likely
no way will survive the game
unless she uses her disciples to her
advantage.
However, it seems like
they're not the most reliable people
considering recent events.
If it were me, though, I would count
my blessings and escape with you.
The six will be attacked by her,
hypnotized disciples
or be killed by the 12th due
to her compromised ability to see.
Now, if that happens,
the disciples will most likely
try their best to take out the 12th,
meaning we've just killed two birds
with one stone. You're welcome.
The masked men rush them,
so Yuno here throws a rock on the railing
nearby, causing only one of them to look.
Idiot.
She notices the distracted enemy
and she strikes.
The tactic works out, and the 12th
contestant is brutally killed her dope.
Suddenly an explosion goes off
and Yuki here collapses
the priestess reveals
that this was her plan all along.
And these two are going to be killed
by her disciples who holds the kids up
and she gives you a kiss goodbye.
The six checks her diary one last time
and is shocked beyond belief to see that
she now has a dead end flagged, enraged,
Yuno, slashes the guards and run
straight towards the priestess
slicing off her hand.
She pushes Yuki off of the railing
before losing consciousness.
However, he's now forced to run off
because of the disciples.
Yuki hides under the house
and hears the priestess announce
that Yuno's about to be badly wounded
and one of the worst ways imaginable,
if he doesn't reveal himself,
he decides to take the risk
and runs into the open room
where Yuno's being held,
scaring them off with an ax.
The priestess tells him,
though, that there's no hope.
But Yuki here realized something.
His dead end flag was never triggered,
which means he still has options,
which means he still has a chance.
He throws a ball into the air
to distract the disciples,
giving him the opportunity
to throw a dart straight into her diary.
And killing the sixth.
The next day,
Yuki picks up his mom from the airport
and they arrive at home
to find the front window broken.
He checks his diary and realizes
exactly what's going on.
Upstairs, he finds Yuki cleaning his room
and tries his best to avoid his mom
entering his room.
She forces the door open to find him
and, Yuno, staring at a dirty magazine.
That night, they have dinner
and she introduces herself
as Yuki girlfriend,
and she's taking off all the boxes.
And Yuki's mother is an absolute support
of their relationship.
And good thing, too,
because, Yuno, would have been more
than willing to kill Mom
if she didn't approve Yuki's mother
let's, Yuno, sleep in the house overnight.
But they're about to wake up
to an unexpected surprise.
Yuki's mom then introduces them
to this adorable child Reisuke.
who will be staying
for the rest of the day.
But he begins acting strange,
nearly stabbing Yuki here
with a pair of scissors.
The mom tells him to put it down,
so he goes off to the bathroom
and whips up a card that has, Yuno,
his name on it.
His diary is the hyper vision diary,
a picture
diary that only shows three entries a day.
Morning, afternoon and night.
The three of them have dinner
while the mom takes a call.
However, this cheeky kid
has a special surprise for the others.
He's poisoned the vegetables,
but Yuki notices
the vegetables are heavier than usual,
so she decides to put them away.
And that's when Yuki's
diary rewrites itself
for a reason that they haven't yet
realized.
Later,
the kid begins tampering with the bathtub,
planning to electrocute them
when they take a bath.
Suddenly, you can notice
that his diary has changed again, meaning
another diary owner must be nearby.
Shocked the text changes to read
that, Yuno, has been electrocuted
he has no time to run to the bathroom,
so he puts his hairdryer on Turbo
and blows out the power to the house.
He runs upstairs to find her safe,
but they begin to realize
that this kid is more than meets the eye.
Okay, that was terrifying.
This kid has no regard for anyone's
safety.
Rude and is ready to do
the most savage things
to kill and eliminate us from the game.
We know that this kid possesses
the intelligence level of an adult,
and that's extremely dangerous.
Now, at this point,
there's no doubt that this kid
is the diary owner
while it might sound like a terrible thing
to do to a child,
what they should have done is grab
the kid and smash his skull
in on the bathtub and teach him a lesson.
However, this kid is a kid, after all,
and I don't think Yuki's
mom would be too happy about it
that we just killed the kid.
She's been babysitting,
and the kid is a crafty one.
But this is Yuki's house,
and he knows the place inside and out.
He should be using his surroundings
to his advantage
to take the kid out without him or, Yuno,
being blamed.
Accidents happen all the time, folks,
don't they?
What we can do is kill the kid
in our sleep along with our mom.
Now hear me out.
You might be wondering why we have to kill
our mother alongside the kid.
And here's why. If we win this game,
we become God.
This means that
whatever actions we've taken during
the game should be able to be reversed.
Desperate times
call for desperate measures,
and Yuki here should do whatever it takes
to eliminate another contestant.
After the kid falls asleep,
Yuki suggests that they just killed
the kid in cold blood.
However, Yuno here suggests
they break his diary instead.
That's when he walks out and tells them
they have no chance of finding it.
Checking around the house,
Yuno's diary shows
no signs of other diaries,
and she decides
to dig around the house with Yuki.
But when he turns around, she disappears.
Yuno, decides to take matters
into her own hands and chases
the kid around the house with a hammer,
with a swing and a miss,
she accidentally hits Yuki's
mom and knocks her out.
They realize that their current methods
aren't going to work.
So, Yuno, decides to put herself
in the mind of a child and she realizes
that the kid has order to package delivery
and that the diary is hidden inside of it.
Suddenly, Yuki's diary changes
and says that the package
is about to release poison gas.
He opens it and passes out
but the kid creepily here has a gas
mask handy,
and he reveals
that the poison wouldn't have activated
if he opened the package
from the other side.
And now they're both screwed.
They hide in the toilet away from the gas
while the kid proposes.
They play a game of hide and seek.
If they win, he'll hand over the antidote,
Yuno, goes added alone, covering her mouth
while running outside,
and she searches every single nook
and cranny of the house
but can't manage to find out
where the kid went.
Finally, she sees him
while running up on the second floor.
However, this kid doesn't
want to play by the rules.
She notices water flowing down the stairs,
and that's when the kid throws a light
bulb down,
electrocuting, Yuno,
just as he's about to finish the job.
Yuki fires the dart of the kid
and he runs off, Yuno,
recovers and walks upstairs,
finding the kid completely defenseless.
Without a mercy, she brutally stabs
the kid through the chair.
Two weeks later, Yuki joins a new school,
but is greeted by a familiar face,
this bully, Corsica.
And he starts to try and tell everyone
what Yuki did when their previous school
got blown to smithereens.
However, this busty
looking girl Hinata hits the bully
and tells him to stop causing problems
and her polite friend Mao walks in
and they introduce themselves to Yuki.
After school,
the four of them meet up with Yuno
and they decide to take a look
at a nearby crime scene.
They find chalk marks on the way
and realize
that they're in the right direction
and they find themselves
on top of the city and hid under here,
goes ahead without them.
And she finds herself caught in a forested
area completely alone.
And that's
when something sinister strikes Yuki.
And you realize that their diaries have
changed, which can only mean one thing.
There's another contestant nearby.
He checks his diary to see a text saying
Hinata's corpse is on the hill ahead
and they run towards the forested area
and find a dismembered arm.
Beyond that, as Hinata's
dead body suddenly
and with an insane amount of creepy
coincidence, this white haired
kid, Akise, shows up out of nowhere
to lend them a hand
while vicious dogs walk out of the forest
and chase the group as they run
as fast as they can
to a nearby observatory.
Okay. These definitely aren't
your run of the mill dogs.
They're huge.
Hinata here is dead meat,
and we should let that go.
And move on because we're going to be next
if we don't do something fast.
However, while it might have worked out
for some reason, running away
from a group of rabid dogs
is the worst thing that you can do
in a situation like this.
Japan is in a country known
for being overrun
with feral dogs like these bad boys, but
it does have a large population of dogs
with the Japanese owners
owning over 8.5 million dogs with this,
many of them, some of them are bound
to end up escaping and becoming feral.
Now, the first thing you should do
is not panic
hard to do, I know, but
dogs are capable of smelling fear,
which may or may not make them
want to approach us even more.
Either way, it's better to keep your cool
and make yourself look as big
and intimidating as possible.
If this doesn't work and the dogs
keep approaching us.
It might be better to think up
some other options.
Most dogs are capable of outrunning
humans, and this means it's a bad idea.
Again, to run,
we need to look around our environment
for things
that we can use to keep us safe.
The only thing in our general
vicinity are trees.
So that should be our next best bet.
Our group consists of five people,
including ourselves,
which means that we can use
the other four as bait.
Some of the group has the physical ability
to climb up the trees, I'm sure,
but there's bound to be a few
that can't manage it
all that well and will be forced to run.
This would grab the attention of the dogs
and leave us with a window of opportunity
to run in the opposite direction.
Back into town, making it safely inside.
The kid introduces himself as a world
famous detective, but, Yuno, interrupts
to say that the dogs might be controlled
by one of the people here.
Suddenly,
the dogs begin to make their way inside.
Yuki reads his diary,
which confirms that he doesn't have long
before the canines
rips them all to shreds.
Using his diary,
he commands everyone to hold alternating
windows down
so the dogs can't break through.
After hours
of holding down the fort, the dogs
finally run off and leave the kids alone.
Kousaka
compliments him on his strategic prowess,
and Yuki admits that his cell phone
told him exactly what to do.
Hearing this Mao comes from behind
and holds a knife to his neck.
She takes his cell phone,
and that's when he walks in.
She reveals herself also as a diary owner.
However, Yuki isn't her target.
Akise is she explains that she left
a dead body as a decoy.
And Yuki here was bait
to get Akise out of hiding.
Akise tells her that
he'll hand over the phone, but first
he has to guess which hand the coin is in.
But with Yuki's diary,
she knows exactly what's going to happen.
So she picks the right hand
just as it says on the screen.
Yuki motions
towards, Yuno, in order to let her know
what hand she's going to play.
But he's not
here, knows exactly what's going on
and changes the coin to her left hand.
However, Akise, say, picks the left hand
and ends up winning the game,
and he never checks
the diary to see even more entries pop up.
And he proposes
that they start the game for real.
Now it's Akise turn.
She bets on the right hand,
but she's wrong
and the girls are forced to let Yuki free,
suddenly, Yuno, push his white haired
Akise the floor and forces him to admit
whether or not he's a diary owner.
And he tells them
that it was just pure luck
that he won and suggests that they resumed
the game to get Yuki's diary back
and they agree for one final game.
If Akise wins, he gets the diary.
If he wins, they get fed to the dogs.
She puts the coin in a right hand
and, Yuno, covers Yuki's ear.
Okay, here.
Guesses the right hand,
but pretends that he got it wrong to Yuki.
Now, his diary changes
based on his internal belief.
Meaning he and I
here can't use it as a method to win.
However, it's not a foolproof plan.
Okay. Here has a 50 50 chance
to win the game.
And he managed to win.
Suddenly, Yuki sprints towards Hinata
with deadly intentions,
but Mao here jumps in front of her
and takes a knife to her body.
The rest of them
then decide to leave the observatory.
But Hinata here isn't satisfied
She calls the dogs to chase them down.
But Akise here
suggests that they split up.
The three of them distract the dogs
while Yuki tries to save Hinata.
The two boys leave, but, Yuno, decides
to head back to the observatory as well.
When they arrive, Yuno sprints
over to Hinata and threatens
to slit her throat
if she doesn't call off the dogs.
Yuki tells, Yuno, not to kill her
just destroy her diary.
Instead, she tells Yuki that she's scared
of Hinata and Yuki's relationship.
Thinking that they might be dating.
But Yuki says, hail to the No,
no, and calls you
his girlfriend, to which,
thank DEUS, calms her down.
Surprised he ended up thanking him
for his forgiveness.
Some time later, Yuki carries
Yuno back to her house inside,
he finds Akise, waiting for them.
He then realizes that the room
with the dead
bodies has been opened and freaks out.
However, they walk inside to find it
completely empty.
And a massive hole has been dug out.
The boys walk home together
and Akise, theorizes
that, Yuno, has completely forgotten
about the dead body incident
because of her fragile mental state.
Meanwhile, at the police station,
the detective informs
the officers about Hinata's
father's death.
He tells them that
he's found two potential suspects.
Yuki and Yuno, think about what Akise.
said Yuki here begins to realize that he's
the only thing keeping, Yuno, from going
absolutely insane. And that's terrifying.
That's when he's approached by Nishijima
and the police
who ask him to come to the station.
Him and Yuno end up at the station
waiting to be interrogated.
And Yuki here is called to go first.
And meets up again with the detective.
Fourth, the man asks him
if he wants to play
a game of Russian roulette
and informs him that they no longer
have an alliance together.
The detective wants to become God,
and there's nothing he can do about it.
Suddenly, Yuno,
forces herself in and shoots
the detective multiple times, killing him.
They then take the detectives
assistant hostage and run off.
However,
they don't realize that they've made
a huge mistake because the detective
was wearing a bulletproof vest.
Since he holds an investigation diary,
this means he can predict the future
when a legal case appears,
which is exactly what's happening
right now.
They run to the fire exit
while being chased by the guards inside.
One of the officers threatens
to shoot them.
Yuki here fears for his life and reacts
by shooting the officer in the stomach.
He's just killed
someone in cold blood for the first time,
and there's no going back from there.
They then run all the way to the roof
and blew a kiss each other before
jumping off onto the roof of a truck.
How romantic.
Okay, now I will admit
that was a ballsy move
and had an extremely good chance
of going terribly wrong.
And it should have.
Judging by the size of the building, it
looks to be over ten or so stories tall.
While it might not sound like much.
Doctors
estimate that a seven story drop a.k.a.
48 feet will lead to a 90% chance
of people dying.
Terribly painful deaths.
Now, it might have worked out in the end,
but there are a few other options
they could have taken
that one would have risk them
of being paralyzed
for the rest of their lives or dead.
Looking at the assistant
we can clearly see that
the man was not going to shoot them.
This gives us a little bit of time
to think about the situation
at hand and consider the negatives
of jumping off of this roof potentially
we could have pretended
to surrender ourselves to the police
and taken the assistant as our hostage.
With this,
we could have grabbed his gun
and kept it for ourselves
to make sure we have some kind of offense
to deal with the incoming officers.
It's only a matter of minutes ago
that Detective Fourth
was trying to play a game of Russian
roulette with a teenage boy.
I don't know about you,
but that's pretty darn messed up.
If we can convince everyone
to stop shooting each other,
then we might be able to suggest
that we can check
the surveillance footage
in the interrogation room to prove
that we're just some innocent teenager and
that the fourth is the real bad guy here
because he's the one pointing a gun at us.
A teenager sounds pretty convincing to me.
The next day, the couple, aka, turned
fugitives are now hiding away
from any police
or civilians, and their diaries
predict dead ends if they leave for food.
So they're stuck inside this
freakin tiny shed with nowhere to go,
absolutely starving.
They smell donuts and take a look outside
to find this smart looking lady
heading to the hospital.
They follow her inside
when suddenly a bomb goes off
and the ninth restrains Yuki
and he accidentally presses
a button that causes another bomb
to go off, leaving
the two stuck Yuno goes to find a ladder
and puts it down for Yuki to cross.
But the ninth, it demands
that she go first,
and she proposes
that they form an alliance for now
and immediately
gets a dead end on her phone.
The message states that the detective
will kill her, but she ignores it.
She promises to tell them
why the detective betrayed them
and opens up the hospital door
to find the smart lady from before
she's the detective's wife
and this is his son.
He's terminally ill,
and the fourth wants to become God
in order to save him,
which makes everything that the fourth
the just did totally morally okay
and in the right.
Realizing that all three of them have dead
ends in their diaries, they tie his wife
up to use her as a bargaining tactic.
Fourth tells Yuki to scout the area.
While Yuno watches the hostages.
She gives him a grenade
and the kid heads off.
Neither calls the detective and tries
to negotiate a deal.
But he doesn't care.
Armed forces have surrounded the building
and he's not backing down.
He decides to take matters
into his own hands
and tells his assistant
to go find the hostages.
Yuno, tells Yuki to run,
but it's too late.
The soldiers take him down
and restrain him.
Suddenly, the detective and unit sprint
towards each other with vicious intent,
taking out all the soldiers
in the process.
The detective grabs
Yuki and points a gun to his head,
but Yuno, here threatens to detonate
a grenade if he doesn't let go.
Meanwhile,
the ninth sets a timer for a bomb.
In 5 minutes, the entire building
will be blown to shreds.
And she uses the bedsheets
to rappelled down to the ground floor,
but runs into the detective's
assistant on the way.
The detective decides to let Yuki go
and tells Yuno to put the grenade down.
Suddenly, she pulls the pin on the grenade
and grabs the detective by the neck.
However,
it turns out to be a flash grenade,
leaving the three of them incapacitated.
Noticing this from below ninth
and the detective's
assistant run to their location,
Yuki wakes up in a pile of rubble
and the detective grabs Yuno
with a knife to her neck.
Yuki finds a gun, but checks his diary
and sees that shooting
the detective isn't going to work out
with no other option.
He takes the chance anyway, and the bullet
lands right into the fourth stomach.
Now he's pissed
and he tries to slice Yuno
but his assistant
and the ninth interrupt the action
and calm him down.
Ninth whips out her phone and shows
evidence of the detective promising
to give her police information
to keep her safe.
Hearing this, the detective's assistant
formally places the fourth under arrest,
and they tell him
that his wife and kids are safe.
So the detective decides to spare them
the trouble and breaks his phone,
eliminating him
from the game
and disappears into thin air.
After the incident,
Yuki and Yuno names are cleared
and they no longer
have to worry about the police.
Luckily for Yuki, that cop was pretty
damn strong and survived the gunshot.
The couple then decides to go on a day
trip and waits for the train to visit.
Yuki is dead.
That's when suddenly Yuki here
gets a text from Aki, say,
telling him to stay away from, Yuno
the police are following her
for unknown reasons
and that he should keep his distance.
However, Yuno,
here is the one reading the text
and she deletes the message before he
comes back and they then board the train.